hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
sir in kierkegaard's essay the present
age which is often presented entirely on
its own
is actually part of a review essay that
he wrote
the two ages contrasting a
revolutionary age against the current
age that he is living in in denmark in
the
1840s and we could transpose these ideas
into other times other places
in fact we have to do that in order to
make sense of this essay we shouldn't
take it
entirely for granted as applying
completely to
our own time although it does have a lot
of
implications for our present as well
depending on
where we're living and what kind of age
we're in
and so one of the key
things that he tells us about what he's
calling the present age
is that there's a lack of passion
and a lack of action within the present
age by comparison to
its predecessor which is the age of
of revolution so we've got this contrast
going on here and the the age of
revolution people are
are genuinely motivated by lasting
passions for better or for worse as
we'll discover
and they engage in action that commits
themselves so if we're thinking about
kierkegaard
in terms of existential philosophy and
he does use that
term existential several times in this
essay
we can say that the age of revolution
the age
preceding the present age is one in
which
people it's not that it's simply easier
for them to commit themselves
existentially
they in some respects can't escape it
whereas
in the present age it's possible to do
that
and he characterizes the present age
in a number of different ways so here's
a definition that well at least
characterization that he provides but
he says the present age is a sense
essentially
a sensible reflecting age devoid of
passion flaring up in superficial
short-lived enthusiasm
and prudentially relaxing in indolence
right so it is a reflection
age he's going to use that term over and
over and over in this essay we'll come
back
to that in a moment it's also an age he
says uh it's a sensible age he's going
to use that not in terms of a
sensuous age actually that would be more
commitment right the erotic he says has
actually
suffered in this present age
it's a sensible age in that it
calculates it thinks things
out ahead of time it's prudential
it involves common sense he
also is going to talk shortly of it
being an
age of publicity as well he says in
contrast to the age of revolution
which took action the present age is an
age of
publicity so there's a contrast there
between
taking action and what he's calling
publicity which is
sort of a substitute for action and you
might think about this
you know in a different context here's
an analogy you can use
we know uh from observation and from
experience as well as from
some experimentation that if you are
going to try to do
some some writing or other creative work
it's better not to talk about it too
much because then the talking itself
can become a substitute for the actual
doing which is more difficult and and
requires more from you than just
chattering about it
but you get the same sort of rewards in
in good
feelings from talking about the action
as you would
at least to some degree from doing it
and so
in the age of publicity we have
something similar there's
much more to say about this but here
this should suffice
he says the age of miscellaneous
announcements nothing happens but still
there is instant publicity and
insurrection in this day and age
is utterly unimaginable
but a political virtuoso might be able
to
perform an amazing tour of force of
another kind he would issue invitations
to a general meeting for the purpose of
deciding upon a revolution
wording the invitation so cautiously
even the censor would have to let it
pass
on the evening of the meeting he would
so skillfully create the illusion that
they'd made a revolution
everyone would go home quietly having
passed a very pleasant
evening and you know we can think about
all the people who weigh in
on social media and you know talk about
their engaging in
activism or revolutionary work
or counter-revolutionary whatever it may
be right but
it's it's i mean you can say that that
posting something on twitter is an
action but it's not quite the same thing
as
demonstrating out in front of some place
let alone taking direct action of
of some sort right so publicity and then
he talks about
it also being an age of
anticipation now here's kind of a
strong declaration by him the age of
great and good actions
is past the present age is the age of
anticipation
no no one is willing to be satisfied
with doing something specific everyone
wants to luxuriate in the daydream
he may at least discover a new part of
the world ours is an age of anticipation
even appreciative
acknowledgement is accepted in advance
so um you know this this is a
quite a i mean you might say it's kind
of a dismal view kierkegaard says
it's not meant to be a dismal view i'm
just sort of diagnosing
the conditions of our time which is very
important for
figuring out what we can actually do now
this characteristic
of what we might call an oscillation of
of comportments is very important
he says that there are superficial
short-lived enthusiasms
those are not the same thing as having a
genuine
passion why because they are superficial
they don't reach down into the core of
our being
they are short-lived they're not
something that people are committing to
and sticking with and enthusiasm well
this is a little bit interesting
this is going a little bit beyond what
kierkegaard is saying here but i think
you can see it is in the background
kierkegaard of course is very conversant
with ancient
greek literature and the greek language
and what the meanings of these
these terms that come down to us in the
present are
enthusiasm is having something literally
like spirit blown
into you right it's it's given to you by
something and it was used to describe
say what music might do or what tragic
um poetry might do to the person who is
is presenting it and then to the
audience you might think about
plato's dialogue the ion where there's a
long discussion of this
using magnets and magnetism as
a model for that but the problem is
take away the source and the enthusiasm
goes away
a passion is something within
you it's no longer simply dependent
on this continual you might say
in blowing or whatever we want to call
it this magnetism
so short-lived enthusiasm and then
apathetic
indolence apathetic meaning
you know not committing oneself in terms
of passion
indolence talks about not actually
doing things not engaging in action
and one can in fact be quite busy
in apathetic indolence it doesn't mean
just laying in bed all day
it could be sitting there watching show
after show after
show or scrolling all the way down
you know the social media stuff or you
know
engaging in tracking down
actually not tracking down rabbits but
just going down rabbit holes
in wikipedia or sitting at the cafe and
chattering
with one's friends about you know the
current situation
how we have to do something but nobody
actually ever doing anything right all
of those are
versions of apathetic indolence it
doesn't have to be
laying around in bed and never making
your bed and maybe having breakfast
all the time over and over in bed but
those are those are characteristic of
the present
age i think that we learned something
about the
what what kierkegaard is calling action
when we look at his characterization of
the previous age
so here's a passage that's very
important from the essay just before the
present age
he says the age of
revolution is essentially
passionate it's essentially passionate
therefore it has not nullified the
principle of contradiction and
can become either good or evil and
whichever way is chosen the impetus of
passion is such
that the trace of an action marking its
progress or its taking a wrong direction
must be perceptible it is obliged
to make a decision but this again is the
saving factor
for decision is the little magic word
that existence
respects now that is something really
interesting
to say is it not let's talk first what
he means by the principle of
contradiction here
he doesn't mean the principle of
non-contradiction in a merely logical
sense
where we say that you know something
cannot be
and also not be in the same way at the
same time
etc etc with all these qualifications
that eventually have to be brought
in that's that's theoretically true
right aristotle points out that hey you
want to deny it
you're going to end up using it it's
very difficult to get away from now of
course there are logics in which we
play around with other ideas kierkegaard
is not
primarily interested in the theoretical
here he's interested in
action and there is a principle of
contradiction
involved in action as well and in this
case it tells us at least in certain
points well you can't act
and not act in the same way at the same
time
which also means you
as the agent have to decide
or something else is going to decide for
you you you get this or you get that
and you have to take a stand now when
you have passion
that is going to help you take that
stand
reflection is going to work against that
and so this is why he can say that
[Music]
here we go it can become either good or
evil and whichever way is chosen the
impetus
is such that the trace of an action
marking its progress or taking the wrong
direction must be perceptible
now the person who engages in evil we
can have all sorts of discussion well do
they really know it's evil when they're
doing it yet
for kierkegaard sometimes you you can
actually know it
and you can certainly afterwards like
look back and go
oh man we did the wrong thing there but
we
chose to do the wrong thing we committed
ourselves
and the present age according to
kierkegaard is an age in which
many people never get that far
they they don't engage
in actions like that he says
so here's a great example action and
decision are just as scarce these days
as is the fun of swimming dangerously
for those who swim in shallow water
now notice the contrast there swimming
dangerously
swimming you know in cases where you
could in fact get hurt or get killed
and and just remaining in the shallow
water
so he says just as an adult reveling in
the tossing waves calls out to those
younger
come on out just jump in quickly just so
does decision lie in existence so to
speak
although of course it is in the
individual and shouts to youth who is
not yet innervated by too much
reflection and overwhelmed by the
delusions of reflection
come on out jump in boldly even if it is
a rash leap
if only it is decisive and if you have
the makings of a man the danger in life
severe judgment on your recklessness
will help you to
become one so he's not saying that
everybody in our present age
is so it's used the word enervated
meaning worn out
meaning you know lacking energy
lacking resolve it is possible for
people to make what kierkegaard
over and over again calls the leap and
notice that he's talking here about
existence again existence
at least it presents us with the option
of jumping out and taking an action
taking a stand
but many people don't he also has a
really great example of ice skating he
says if the treasure everyone covets
lies far out on a very thin crust of ice
guarded by the great danger to anyone
venturing so far out
whereas let us assume this oddity which
after all is only odd in the
illustration closer to shore the ice is
thick and solid
in a passionate age the crowd would
loudly cheer the bold brave person
who skates out on the thin ice they
would shudder for him and with him in
his
perilous decision would grieve for him
if he meets his death
would idealize him if he gets the
treasure notice that there's passion
there right
grieving idolizing all these sorts of
things
what's the case with the present age and
this goes to the sort of
not just reflection but the sensibility
part
he says the situation would be entirely
different in a reflective age devoid of
passion
in mutual recognition of shared prudence
they would sensibly agree that
it certainly would not be worth the
trouble to skate out on such thin ice
in fact it would be foolish and
ridiculous then an inspired venture
would be transformed into an acrobatic
stunt so there's two things going on
here
there's one is saying there's that
treasure this thing that's
really valuable but you know it's not
prudent to go
out beyond where the ice could could
could you know crack
and you could be lost trying to gain
that that treasure that would that would
be
silly wouldn't it and yet they have
people who do skate out there
not past the point of
danger though he this is a how it's
transformed into an acrobatic stunt in
order to do something
for something has to be done they would
go out and from their safe vantage point
a praise
with the air of connoisseurs the expert
skater who can skate
almost to the very edge that is as far
out as the ice is still safe and just
short of being dangerous
and then turn back one of the skaters
would be exceptionally skilled and he
would even be able to perform the stunt
of making one
seemingly hazardous swoop right at the
very edge
causing the spectators to shout ye gods
he is crazy he is risking his life but
this is not him risking his life this is
just being prudent and skillful
and giving a little bit of titillation
rather than genuine
passion and so what we have here in
these two examples
is one that has to do with action
primarily
jump in take the leap the other has to
do
with the passion of the spectators oh
he's getting so close to the edge but
it's not really passion is it
it's just again this sort of stuff that
goes along with the present age and so
you know is are there no actions
whatsoever kierkegaard doesn't say that
he tells us that a person stands or
falls on his actions is becoming
obsolete we no longer judge a person
just by
how they commit themselves everyone sits
around and does a brilliant job of
bungling through with the aid of some
reflection
and also by declaring that they all know
very well what is to be done
but what people two by two in
conversation with individuals as readers
or participants in a general assembly
understand brilliantly in the form of
reflection and observation
they would be utterly unable to
understand in the form of action
and there are still people who act
but they they are now becoming less and
less comprehensible
to those who sit back and just
reflect who think about things who don't
act because of that
now these actors the ones who actually
do
something he says nobody can really
predict them and if somebody did
something
everyone would be taken aback and they
would find it rash
but it's interesting because then
reflection comes back in and says
oh well i guess that's the way it had to
work and you see this over and over
again
i mean great example of this if you're
if you know anything about academia are
committee meetings right people will
dither and dither and it's amazing to
see these
otherwise seemingly quite dynamic and
intellectual people
going back and forth and wasting all
this time
eventually somebody might actually say
listen we're going to do this
and that's the end of the story and then
people oh
that's not collegial but usually they'll
actually be like well
okay since you feel strongly about that
we'll go along with you
and then everyone's like i guess this is
all this works out just fine
right because the key thing was to
decide something
not necessarily to have the best
decision
you know and it could turn out to be a
bad decision in retrospect but at least
it's a decision
now he also talks about this age as
being a revolutionary age but not an age
of revolution
he talks about it as being uh here we go
he contrasts it with a passionate
tumultuous age that wants to throw aside
overthrow everything and set aside
everything then he says an
age that is revolutionary but also
reflecting and devoid of passion
changes the expression of power into a
dialectical
tour de force meaning you know there's
this excellent thing that's being done
showing a kind of virtuosity and it's
doing through doing so through
what kierkegaard here is calling
dialectics which you know there's a lot
of different meanings to this
term right we're not going to like try
to worry about
teasing out every every meaning of it
but but essentially
dialectics means that there's some sort
of
engagement between things and it can be
done
you know too much through reflection
where it never actually arrives at
an answer but it's also how things are
connected together
so he says what happens in in this age
it lets everything remain but subtly
drains the meaning
out of it rather than culminating in an
uprising it exhausts the inner actuality
of a relations
in a tension of reflection that lets
everything remain
and yet has transformed the whole of
existence
into an equivocation that in its
facticity is
while entirely privately a dialectical
fraud interpolates a secret way of
reading
that is not now that sounds you know
very
jargon heavy so we should talk about
some of the things
that he's saying here particularly this
last part
it's transformed the whole of existence
into an equivocation what is an
equivocation an equivocation
is where you're saying a term and that
term has multiple
meanings now it becomes an equivocation
rather than just being an equivocal term
when you shift from one meaning to the
other
and at least somebody isn't realizing
that that's going on and they think that
you're talking about the same thing when
you're really not talking about the same
thing
when you know some sort of clarification
or analysis
or decision would have been required and
he says that
in its factity meaning in in the way
that
it simply is within the world so
as human beings within existence
we ought to be committing ourselves or
perhaps
maybe there isn't an auth there but
that's certainly a possibility for us
the age that we're in is one where the
meaning has been
been drained out of everything it's
still there
but we don't have the value we don't
have the drive the impetus
and he talks about attention of
reflection this is going to be
quite important as we move on through
the work
because there's a lot going on there
but it's enough to say that this is an
age
in which because of the let's call it
the availability
and the social desirability
of reflection many people are not
acting in any genuine sense they're not
committing themselves
existentially and they're not doing so
action is correlative for hi
for uh kierkegaard i would say in this
respect to
passion if you're not genuinely not just
motivated by the passion where the
passion automatically leads the action
but where the passion spurs you
to a point where you do have to decide
and act
then there's a sort of let's call it
existential
superficiality involved
you